(groaning)
(breathing heavily)
- That was a super important moment.
Those are the two things
that hold you back.
The two things that hold everybody back.
(whirring sounds)
(upbeat music)
Ask, so many of you are just not asking.
You are the fear of rejection,
or the laziness of the execution,
is stopping people from winning.
- Hashtag laziness I think
that is very very strong point.
- It is one of those two things, Marcus.
I'm telling you right now, if
you actually have a product
and you actually spend 10 hours a day.
And I love when people
were like 10 hours a day,
I was running a very large
wine retail business.
And when Twitter came out,
I went (mumbles) committed all in
and I was spending 10 hours a day.
I built my entire brand
from that ecosystem.
It's unbelievable, what 10
hours a day of asking 850 chefs
a day on Instagram,
109 chefs will take a
photo with your olive oil,
39 moms that have a lot of other,
moms that give (mumbles).
We'll take a photo with your olive oil
and it's just the work and the asking.
(upbeat music)
That was a super important moment.
Those are the two things
that hold you back.
The two things that hold everybody back.
(upbeat music)
That's it. (upbeat music)